so it's nautica yes it's an usual name
thank you it's definitely different it's
like the clothes
all right nautica yes nautica uh where
did you grow up where are you from um
i'm from des moines iowa
are you i know that's so small like no
i've been to but yes yes that's great i
i think it's growing on the map
no devine's a
fairly big city yes it is though i love
that's my home it's not a small town in
iowa it's a big town in iowa no i mean
everybody thinks it's small you know but
it is big it is
it's growing and i love it i love it but
how long have you been how long have you
been in los angeles
um for about six months or something
like you're doing here yeah kind of
still how was your how was your
childhood
oh
um
i was i'm a foster child so my mom
my foster mom raised us
it was hard but
she tried
and did well so
i don't know but i mean you know grew up
there
and then turned 18 and i went to college
he went to college for a little while it
didn't last so long sadly but i tried
how would you describe your childhood
um
honestly it was kind of harder
it was harder
um
i'm i'm visually impaired and stuff so
you know i i learned a lot
um and i had to learn how to be very
independent
how visually impaired are you
um so okay so like
it's kind of hard to explain right so
i've seen the left a little bit and then
the right like none right but the left
is like things are close so like
you know i could see you a little bit
but like not like your facial features
you know but i could see you like as a
whole
right so you have something things that
are close and like colors all that but
like clothes they're doing this kind of
work yeah
yeah things bad things can happen
so not having your vision makes it
tricky right
i don't believe so i and like like like
we're saying like it stems back to how
you grow up like
i wasn't baby right like straight up
right like i wasn't babied a lot like i
had to learn a lot and when you learn
and you have the skills and the mindset
you can do whatever you want to do like
and that's so so everybody says all that
but like really like i i've been doing
this for
the blade for like almost a year and
it's so easy like
there's just things different things
that i do
that
to keep myself cautious and to be safe
and to be where like a lot of my people
that i interact with don't even know i'm
blind i'm like i'm so good like it's so
it really is
yeah tell people people know i would
think that you if you did let them know
right they would try something no i
think i think it would be the opposite
the likelihood that somebody's going to
take advantage of you might be less
i
because i think a lot of it is fueled by
anger
yes against women
yes it is and if you're already
visually impaired or blind or whatever
you're not you're not going to want to
hurt you i i would think
i i actually had the opposite where like
where i've like oh yeah like i'm joking
with them and oh i think they're all
right yeah i'm actually blind you know
that ha ha you know then they'll try to
like give me
fives and stuff
20s oh yeah people yeah that's
disappointing here
people are so and then and it'll be the
person where you really think they're
really cool and everything and like oh
this person's all right i can just tell
them can you tell the difference between
a five and a half yes yep yep so i can
see a little bit where it's like 5 10 20
and then i fold it you know when i get
it to myself i fold it and organize it
in a way where it's efficient for me to
find but i also you know i can feel if
it's fake and all that like um like you
sure this hunter's real because it feels
kind of papery sir
like hold on typically when people have
one of their senses that are
limited as yours is other ones are
heightened
i mean people people say that i i feel
like i don't really know if that's quite
true but maybe i
i maybe i do feel like have more of into
it it's something but it's definitely
it's not like super power hearing but
it's definitely something going on like
like feeling feeling things deep
how old am i i'm 24. 24.
yeah
and
do you
so your foster parents know you're doing
this
no i'm not with my foster
people i'm with my foster my my regular
family i found them when i was 16.
yeah it's a long it's a lot let's hear
it but it's okay well yeah so i was
adopted but me you know it wasn't it was
sh i love her bless her heart but you
know but yeah i found my biological
family and
why did they lose you in the first place
um she she was very young and just kind
of struggling with life and we were
taken
so
[Music]
but i always remembered her and
i love her and um now we're kind of
working on building our relationship now
that i grew up and stuff so it's it's
kind of a beautiful story it's like a
bittersweet but it's beautiful
so that's how i started it like i i
moved out to the to phoenix and then i
started and then now i'm here how did
you get introduced to prostitution
oh a friend a friend of mine homegirl it
was actually kind of hilarious talking
about oh yeah my brother thinks they're
cute
let's hang out
but it's okay i thought i'd try it out
and it turned out to be something i
actually found that i was really good in
because you know i used to take the bus
and go to work and like do all that like
by myself like for real like i'm super
like self like i have department stuff
all that like you know so really like
when you know your skill like you could
do whatever you want like so yeah i used
to work like at different stores and
marshalls and charlotte roost little
stores you know i had little jobs and
stuff but i started doing this and i was
like wow like as long as i'm careful as
long as i know what i'm doing like
this is something like i've been doing
for a while
and i've i found something i really like
so i'm like yeah and you do this on your
own or with the pimp or no i just do it
on my own you know i got some friends
some help somehow partners but just me
you know
me myself now and how much money will
you make in a night
um you know really depends on different
cities like i try to like out here you
know sometimes maybe like good luck you
know a good amount like five ten five to
ten every day is my goal
you know five to a thousand every day is
the goal
you know like seven eight nine you know
nine
eleven on real good days if you know so
you know it kind of fluctuates but
try to rack it up as much you can
thank you so you have a good attitude
about it yes my [ __ ] you don't find
yourself getting depressed or down or
anything like that
no not really you know
sometimes it gets you get frustrated but
you just got to keep going like it's
okay like any job you know life is life
you know
but you just got to find your happiness
and what makes you happy and professions
that make you
but what makes you happy
um when i have a successful
time
when i have a good time make some money
invest in where i need to invest in when
you make a ban
exactly
like a good day
yes
that does i'm like yes
success
and what
a blind prostitute
you're working figueroa yes
your visual your vision has to be a big
part of how you do this but
um without that honestly like how i do
it how i do like let's just say i'm
actually standing there right like i'm
standing there i'm on like one of the
little streets little side streets
you know um so like
when i
when i know a car is coming up you know
i'm gonna say hey babe
it might be
let's say it's a pe or something let's
say it's like a a person right or
somebody you know and they stay talking
you know okay
okay you gotta say hey now you know who
it is ain't nothing wrong saying hey
just say hey
oh they say susan oh all right gotta go
you don't even say none you pretend like
you're
you're you have your vision yeah exactly
the more honest yeah the more that you
do the more people can't screw with you
you know what i mean because when you
seem vulnerable you can't just be
standing out there all vulnerable and
[Music]
that's going to attract the wrong person
you know
like
you can't look too
you know have you had bad things happen
to you like oh yeah like i've had some
bad experiences you know what i mean a
couple in the past but when i first
started you know
well i'm not you know you kind of live
and learn yeah everybody's had were
there were those cases where somebody
knew your vision was not no 100
no not really it was just kind of they
just wanted to
be kind of silly yeah they wanted my
iphone and
or whatever
or you know they would just want to get
something off for free and they just see
a girl they think oh some small girl
let's just try a duran you know other
than that you know it's okay but even
those things you can't let that scare
you away like you can't let that stop
you in life like
who cares like people are gonna
people are gonna tell you no no no but
you gotta prove to them like yes yes yes
like so many times and it's okay like
it's okay like you gotta believe in
yourself if you want to do something you
figure out how to [ __ ] do it period
like it's your life you know be happy
like with your life
so that was much meal but yeah
doing this kind of work does it
does it
build up your self-esteem somehow yeah
no um i definitely think about you
i think
first you gotta have your own
self-esteem before you go out there you
gotta know you're beautiful you gotta be
able to look in the mirror and be like
yes like i'm beautiful because your
your confidence is what's gonna what's
gonna help you
you know the more you look confident and
happy and like hey like
you know that's going to attract people
more
um yeah sometimes it can make you feel
good like if you got off a good date or
whatever but your self-esteem comes
within yourself
first
you know so have you been in love before
have i been in love
um
i don't really
too often because i i'm i i'm way too
hard with feelings like feelings to my
feelings shoot i feel everything like so
i don't i try not to too much because
i'll care too much
and
so
it's okay
but yeah you're young
yeah yeah kind of just like living life
right now but
you know sometimes but you know then i'm
like all right moving on
what do you think of this life where
everyone you're dealing with is is is up
to no good you know the tricks
that i don't i don't really look at like
that everybody's up to no good but just
like just kind of watch out you know
like
you know just watch yourself you know
just
i feel like it's all right most people
are all right as long as you
as long as you're cautious and you're
just getting in the right cars just
making sure you're getting in the right
cars like you know someone's coming up
all sketch like don't just don't even
get in the car with them ever first and
that's somebody who's blind or not blind
like some of it's really just like
common sense yeah i mean you know your
intuition must be something you live by
yes like yeah like okay this person
seems sketch i'm not even gonna deal
with it
i'm really not
like nope next
you know like don't even put yourself in
it do you think you're addicted to this
kind of i do like it i mean
for a while i definitely do think this
is what i want to do like it's a great
way to like stack up and like
reach some goals you know
for sure and it's fun
for the most part but it's crazy i mean
you must it is crazy it's a crazy life
but it's a fun life is that the
attraction in some ways i mean it's you
definitely feel like you definitely
don't not have a life if that's what you
mean like yeah like it's definitely a
life style
but it would it could be a good
lifestyle what have you learned about
people or men
um
men
um i feel like i've learned that as long
as i'm
when i do my services like i treat them
how
how i feel the vibe like if they got
you know they seem like they got a whole
lot you know when they're and they're
kind and they're actually being decent
like okay that's great like okay this
person's great but i mean if there's you
know douchey and whatever okay might not
be as hot honey you know
so it's okay they whatever treatment
is whatever treatment they want like
you know i'm super nice but you know
better better
the more you give the more you get
are are drugs a part of your life
um
not a whole lot i mean i like weeds a
lot of girls have to drink or get high
or something i mean i like a lot of weed
but i mean if it comes along like you
know some coke or something or some eggs
but
not too much but hey if it's there you
know it's cool
but really just weed maybe a little
drink every now and then but not too
much what advice would you give to a
young young woman who's thinking of
doing this kind of work
i definitely say do it for the right
reasons don't just
don't do it to look
don't do it trying to look for
anything but your goals just really have
that your first priority in this your
goals don't get wrapped up in people or
in things
if you have a team stay with your team
but just
do just have goals just have goals
really don't just do it just to get some
hair and go shopping and get something
to eat like okay that's fun for a while
but really it's more to it than that
you're really
having a goal whether that's to go back
to school
get your place
what are your goals that's right my
goals um i kind of want to save a little
bit for school to go back to college
but i'm thinking about it
but then also i really want to get an
apartment like a really really nice
apartment right now are you just saying
motel of the motel now yeah i just kind
of stay in hotels right now like nice
nicer ones you know
but yeah i kind of want to get another
place again
um and then just save up and you know i
want to get a laptop and something so i
want to go you know a couple things but
yeah
and what do you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
24 years
oh my whole 24 years of life
um
um
don't
don't try not to take no for an answer
try to find
a way to compromise or a way to work
things out
that's right that's what i've learned i
don't know that's hard to explain but
yeah that's good that's great for sure
for sure
find a way to love yourself
no matter what you're doing it's
important because this is great
and just love your own life like and
live your own life and do whatever makes
you happy
yeah
all right not again well thank you so
much for coming in and talking with me
thank you be careful arthur i will i
will i am
thank you guys
you